figure live bonjour voilà plus d'un mois
que le Hamas a lancé une attaque contre
Israël et que la repost a eu lieu nous
allons vous faire un point sur les
dernières informations dont nous
disposons grâce aux cartes du service
infographie et pour vous en parler je
suis avec amori coutané bonjour amori
bonjour Vincent Roson merci d'être avec
nous aujourd'hui donc je le disais on va
faire un point alors vous n'hésitez pas
bien sûr dans les commentaires du Figaro
et ce YouTube bien sûr à poser vos
questions on y répond au mieux comme
d'habitude Amouri première question un
peu générale mais où est-ce qu'on en est
aujourd'hui alors et et on le voit très
bien sur sur la carte l'armée
israélienne a coupé la bande de Gaza en
deux donc il y a un peu plus un peu plus
au sud effectivement là on voit les les
gros carrés bleus une avancée une percée
de 7 km à peu près de l'armée
israélienne depuis le territoire
israélien jusqu'à la mer Méditerranée et
par le nord donc il y a deux points
d'entrée de l'armée israélienne un qui
est aux alentours de betthanoun que l'on
voit en haut à gauche de la carte et de
l'autre côté à côté de la Méditerranée
année il y a eu une avancée qui atteint
la ville de Gaza et le centreville de
Gaza annoncé l'armée israélienne hier
ils ont même annoncé être à proximité de
l'hôpital Shifa qui serait
potentiellement l'un des gros centres de
commandement voir le quartier général du
Hamas dans la ville de Gaza alors on
voit ça s'est fait en plusieurs étapes
l'une étape a été vraiment de couper
cette bande de Gazin en deux voilà
exactement en ça a commencé en on
pourrait découper le temps en trois
trois étapes la première étape c'était
une campagne de bombardement aérien
ciblé sur des sites de production de
fabrication d'armes de regroupement de
combattants puis d'encerclement de toute
la bande de Gaza avec des blindés et des
soldats et enfin la dernière phase qui a
été lancée il y a 2 semaines un peu plus
de de semaines maintenant une phase
d'incursion au sol donc c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a des blindés donc des chars des
des des des véhicules qui contiennent
des hommes mais aussi des bulldozers
pour dégager la route et éviter qu'il y
ait des mines lors du passage des
soldats et enfin des soldats qui vont
aller progressivement faire du combo
urbain dans la ville de Gaza
c'est-à-dire du voilà pas du porte à
porte mais du bâtiment à bâtiment tout
en il faut également se rappeler qu'il y
a quand même des tunnels un peu partout
sous la bande de Gaza donc ça va être un
combat qui sera probablement extrêmement
meurtrier on sait que le combat urbain
présente plusieurs spécificités que
c'est déjà très difficile et que pour
vaincre dans un tel type de combat il
faut un rapport de force d'un défenseur
pour huit attaquants effectivement alors
là on le voit sur ces images il y a eu
ce ce
coupé coupé en deux alors on a aussi
beaucoup parlé au début d'une attaque
terrestre massive d'Israël finalement ce
qui s'est passé c'est qu'on a avancer
petit à petit du côté de Tal voilà
exactement c'est c'est prudent alors
pour plusieurs raisons la première c'est
comme on en parlait tout à l'heure la
campagne de bombardement aérien à causé
des gravins donc il faut déminer enfin
déminer se frayer un chemin puis le
déminer pour acheminer avec sécurité des
hommes il faut aussi savoir qu'il y a
des opérations qui sont menées dans dans
des endroits qui ne sont pas sous le
contrôle total de l'armée israélienne
pour retrouver les otages eu Benjamin
Benjamin netaniaahou le Premier ministre
israélien en reparlait encore ces
derniers jours les otages sont la
priorité absolue le retrouver les otages
et la priorité absolue de l'armée
israélienne puis le démantelllement du
Hamas évidemment et le fait de couper
euh au droit quasiment cette bande de
Gaza on comprend bien l'objectif l'armée
israélienne avait demandé aux habitants
de de la bande de Gaza de partir du nord
vers le sud et leur idée c'est de petit
à petit vider le nord de la ville le
nord de la bande de Gaza de tous les
civils pour qu'il reste que les
combattants et pouvoir combattre ces
combattants et éliminer le le Hamas et
on rappelle que ce que que cette zone
qui est qui est au nord de la bande de
Gaza est très peuplé très densément
peuplé exactement il faut imaginer que
c'est il y a 2,2 millions d'habitants et
que c'est grand comme à peu près tro
fois Paris sauf que c'est extrêmement
concentré notamment dans la ville de
Gaza qui concentre je crois aux
alentours d'un million 1,1 million il
faudrait vérifier d'habitants donc c'est
vraiment extrêmement serré il faut voir
que le contexte urbain sont des
immeubles qui sont plutôt assez haut en
moyenne 6 étaps ét AG pour des rues
assez étroites des immeubles qui ont été
détruits donc il y a des gravas partout
et en dessous de ces immeubles comme
nous en parlions il y a donc ces tunnels
qui permettent aux combattants du Hamas
de se déplacer dans toute la bande de
Gaza et de surgir derrière sur les
arrières israéliens ou sur les côtés
pour détruire qui les munitions qui les
blindé et qui les soldats alors on voit
sur cette carte on a d'abord coupé en
deux et là on a l'impression qu'il se
rapproche pour encercler en fait via le
littoral c'est ça on pourrait même
imaginer une sorte de mouvement de de
Ten de de pinces en fait qui vont se
refermer progressivement comme l'on
casse une noix et qui va se refermer la
noix étant la ville de Gazin et
progressivement ils vont rentrer
investir les lieux fouiller rechercher
essayer de trouver des otages et surtout
détruire tous les centres de
commandement et de les dépôts de
munitions du Hamas dans la ville dans la
ville même de
Gaza la stratégie rappelle un peu ce qui
se passe ce qui se passe en Ukraine
finalement absolument quelque part on
pourrait même comparer ça la ville de
marioopol je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez donc les Russes avaient d'abord
encerclé la ville puis progressivement
avait c l'assaut en réduisant petit à
petit la poche de résistance ukrainienne
jusqu'à cet assaut sur l'usine azoftal
mais ce combat avait duré près de 3 mois
alors ça sont pour les pour les
manœuvres de de l'armée israélienne il y
a toujours la question des otages vous
l'avez dit qui est principale pour benam
netaniaou est-ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui
si cela avance pour la libération de de
ces otages alors avant de venir sur
votre plateau je voyais que le
Qatar disait avoir beaucoup avancé dans
des négoci question avec le Hamas on
sait que au Qatar il y a certains
dirigeants du Hamas et que il y a voilà
des liens ils se connaissent ils peuvent
il y a des canaux de discussion et que
le Hamas en revanche conditionne une la
libération des otages à un cesser le feu
ou à une trêve humanitaire à l'inverse
Israël conditionne sa trêve humanitaire
à la Libération d'otage et voilà pour le
moment on en est là on ne sait pas
vraiment s'il y a eu s'il y aura des
libérations d' Tage dans les dans les
dans les prochains jours on sait que
l'armée israélienne lors d'une incursion
aux alentours de betetanoun avait
trouver un corps du du notage on sait
que certains binationaux notamment des
Américains avaient été libérés avaient
été confié aux autorités égyptiennes au
sud de la bande de Gaza à l'endroit de
du checkpoint de Rafin c'est ça ça alors
ça c'est c'est une carte qui montre
aussi les hôpitaux mais c'est c'est pour
vous montrer là c'est en dzoomant
effectivement la partie qu'on voyait
avec la zone blle qui coupé en 2 c'est
ici et ensuite voilà c'est par ce
passage là drafa au sud en fait voilà
c'est ça c'est le seul il y a 7 point de
passage tout le long de la bande de Gaza
et le seul qui n'est pas contrôlé par
Israël c'est celui de Rafa donc qui
donne sur le Sinaï égyptien c'est par là
qui a acheminé une partie de l'aide
humanitaire internationale à l'intérieur
de Gazin et mais c'est aussi par là que
sont sortis ces derniers temps les
binationaux ou les étrangers qui étaient
au sein de la bande de Gazin et qui ont
donc dû être exfiltrés vers leur pays
d'origine oui parce qu'il y a plusieurs
Français qui sont partis de la bande de
Gaza récemment absolument voilà et qui
ont été rapatriés ensuite il faut
rappeler aussi que ce passage de Rafa il
est bloqué pour pour les pour les autres
personnes l'Égypte empêche les gens de
passer c'est ça de depuis près de 15 ans
maintenant les les les ce point de
passage est fermé par l'Égypte qui ne
qui peut laisser transiter de temps en
temps quelques comment dirais-je
quelquide humanitaire ou quelques
quelques camion voilà pour ravitailler
la bande de Gaza en revanche l'Égypte ne
veut à aucun prix d'importation massive
de réfugiés sur son sol et qui pourrait
ne jamais partir il faut il faut
imaginer que derrière le point de
passage de raface et la péninsule du
sinï c'est une péninsule qui est
désertique qui avait d'ailleurs été
contrôlée à un moment par Israël Israël
l'avait rendu en échange de la paix avec
avec l'Égypte en 1978 79 78 et mais que
cette péninsule est en pro une
insurrection islamiste d'un groupe qui a
fait allégance à l'état islamique
d'ailleurs et qui ne qui et l'Égypte ne
va en aucun cas importer de réfugiés qui
pourrai soit alimenter ce terrorisme si
jamais il y avait des combattants du
Hamas qui est infiltré ou alors soit
prospérer dans la pauvreté aux
frontières de d'Israël et devenir un
endroit absolument ingérable pour
l'administration égyptienne h
effectivement on comprend bien l'enjeu
que ça poste et également pardon le
l'Égypte a un un précédent en tête en
réalité c'est que dans après la guerre
des des 7 jours et même après 48 un
certain nombre de réfugiés palestiniens
avaient trouvé refuge en ce qui était la
TR Jordanie puisqu est devenu la
Jordanie et dans des camps de réfugiés
c'était monté voilà des milices
également l'organisation de la
libération de la Palestine et qui avait
tenté de tuer le roi jordanien de
l'époque Septembre noir et c'est le les
autorités jordaniennes avaient donc
expulsé les combatendant de
l'Organisation de Libération de la
Palestine il avit eu les combats très
durs beaucoup de morts et une partie
d'entre eux étaient partis au Liban qui
en avait accueilli également sauf que au
Liban un certain nombre de voilà de
conflits intracommunautaires ont fait
naître une guerre civile et donc
personne n'a véritablement envie d'un
d'un d'une importation massive de
réfugiés par peur également en plus de
cela de de risque sécuritaire et et de
d'une déstabilisation du pays comme on
pu le connaître à la fois la Jordanie et
le Liban alors on parlait tout à l'heure
de la de
l'évacuation des civils pour les faire
partir de la bande de Gaza il y a aussi
depuis un moment des évacuations l'armée
israélienne demande aux habitants de
gazaville de passer finalement cette
zone bleue pour rejoindre le sud
absolument c'est même un tout petit peu
en dessous de la zone bleue on voit le
le le Wadi Gaza c'est cette espèce de de
de fleuve que enfin de fleuve de rivière
de cour plutôt que l'on voit sur sur la
carte et l'armée israélienne quasiment
depuis le début de ses opérations même
depuis ses bombardements a demandé au
civils de d'évacuer le nord vers le sud
d'y trouver d'y trouver refuge voilà
elle a encore appelé aujourd'hui appelé
entre 10h et 14h mais devant l'afflux
important de réfugiés elle l'a prolongé
d'une heure jusqu'à 15h aujourd'hui euh
un certain nombre de réfugiés
effectivement ont pu y aller on estime à
près d'un million et demi le nombre de
réfugiés dans dans la bande de Gaza de
déplacé interne pardon euh mais euh un
certain nombre étit un certain nombre de
convois avaient été bloqués par le Hamas
des images satellites l'avaient montré
et le Hamas n'a pas complètement intérêt
non plus à laisser partir se réfugier
parce qu'ell lui servent de de bouclier
humain et l'armée israélienne étant
également tenue par le droit
international humanitaire le DIH le
droit qui encadre la guerre ne peut pas
bombarder des civils voilà comme ça pour
pour faire un exemple non c'est c'est
pas possible et donc le l'armée le le
Hamas a beau jeu donc de se cacher dans
des endroits où il y a beaucoup de
civils pour euh éviter d'être frappé par
l'armée israélienne c'est la raison pour
laquelle l'armée israélienne demande
donc à ces civils de partir et une fois
qu'elle estimera que tous ces civils
seront partis il est à peu près
concevable qu'elle qu'elle imagine que
chaque personne qui restera dans les
zones des combats sera tenu pour un
combattant armée et donc pourra être
neutralisé par la par l'armée
israélienne alors j'ai j'ai une question
dans le dans le chat de de maiavel sur
alors là nous sommes dans la bande de
Gaza on va s'intéresser à qui nous parle
de de d'un deuxième VO d'un 3oè front
qui qui pourrait s'ouvrir c'est la
crainte depuis le début de ce conflit en
S Jordanie et au Liban est-ce que euh
depuis le début de la de de de
l'intervention on voit des des des un
second front qui pourrait s'ouvrir
justement c'est l'inquiétude de de de
beaucoup si les États-Unis d'Amérique
ont envoyé euh deux groupes aéronaval
avec deux porortes-avion si la France a
elle-même envoyé un porte hélicoptre
enhiie ça n'est pas pour rien c'est bien
sûr pour euh dire à tous ceux qui
voudraient profiter de cette crise euh
que ce soit des des pays étrangers comme
on peut penser à l'Iran ou des groupes
comme le hzbolin qui est au Liban euh si
vous intervenez nous aussi nous
interviendrons et personne n'a envie
d'une conflagration déconflagration
général ça c'est c'est tout à fait
inenvisageable pour pour la communauté
internationale de manière générale et ça
serait bien sûr c'est le scénario craint
par l'armée israélienne tout d'abord au
au Liban Hassan nasrala donc le chef le
leader du
hbolin a parlé la semaine dernière et a
dit que son mouvement était en guerre
depuis le 8 octobre c'est-à-dire le
lendemain de l'attaque du Hamas en
Israël mais en terme de guerre pour le
moment euh c'est c'est surtout des
échanges de roquettes en réalité de part
et d'autre de la frontière ça l'armée
israélienne a quand même demandé aux
civils dévécu ben voilà t toute la bande
que l'on voit en bleu un peu plus foncé
sur la carte et il y a donc des échanges
de tirs de part et d'autre de la
frontière libanaise de la ligne bleue
mais nous sommes au nord d'Israël au sud
du LAN à cette frontière avec les
différents explosions qu'il y a eu le
long de cette frontière exactement et en
revanche chacun craint une intervention
armée du Hezbollah le hzbollah faut
imaginer que c'est à peu près alors son
leader disait 100000 combattants
probablement plutôt aux alentours de
25000 vraiment combattants gueris mais
c'est un arcelal colossal avec voilà des
blindés des missiles même des drones
donc c'est vraiment autrement plus
important que le Hamas si jamais il
devait entrer en guerre ce serait
vraiment probablement plus meurtrier que
ce que l'on voit aujourd'hui en dans la
bande de Gaza et le second front que que
que notre internaut évoqué effectivement
en 6jordanie alors en 6 Jordanie les
Américains et les Français d'ailleurs
ont fait part de leur préoccupation
parce qu'il y a aussi des attaques de
Colon je rappelle voilà que la sjordanie
depuis les accords de slot 2 sont
séparés en trois zones la zone A qui est
administré par l'autorité palestinenne
donc c'est c'est les grosses villes à
peu près voilà ce que l'on voit en ver
un peu plus foncé la zone B qui est en
vert un peu plus clair donc c'estàdire
que les affaires civiles sont gérées par
l'autorité palestinenne mais sécurité
est assurée par Israël et la zone C qui
est en bleu et où là tout est géré par
l'armée israélienne et dans dans à peu
près toutes ces zones il y a des des
implantations des on qui sont illégales
au regard du droit international et donc
les colons les habitants de de ces
implantations viennent en découdre avec
les Palestiniens il y a même eu des
morts aux alentours de 150 et mais ça
continue de gmper depuis le début du
conflit bien sûr et ce que craint
l'armée israélienne qui fait quand même
des des descentes et des incursions
régulièrement dans ces dans ses camps de
réfugiés ou dans ses villes c'est un
embrasement général à la fois de laass
Jordanie de la bande de Gazin et de se
retrouver sur plusieurs fronts en même
temps à devoir gér
la sécurisation à la fois de son propre
territoire mais aussi de ses colonies où
vivent des citoyens israéliens
effectivement on le comprend bien est-ce
que le soutien à Israël s'étiole depuis
depuis le 7 octobre en réalité je pense
que il y a aussi une perception
médiatique qui a qui a évolué
c'est-à-dire que le 7 octobre ça a été
le moment de voilà de la découverte de
l'horreur à la fois des enlèvements mais
aussi de ces massacre et je pense que ça
fait à peu près un mois aujourd'hui je
sais pas si les gens s'en souviennent
mais c'était vraiment un massacre
horrible plus de 1400 personnes des gens
qui étaient dans un festival des enfants
c'était vraiment absolument horrible et
s'en a en suivi des compagnes de
bombardement sur la bande de Gaza puis
d'incursion de l'armée israélienne et ça
a donné lieu effectivement à la fois sur
les réseaux sociaux mais aussi dans le
débat public on a beaucoup plus parler
de l'incursion israélienne et des morts
que cela pouvait causer évidemment que
de de l'origine de ce conflit je ne sais
pas si le soutien des états va baisser
euh à Israël et je ne le pense pas en
revanche je pense que les opinions sont
de plus en plus balancé en France par
exemple c'est toujours le soutien à
Israël est toujours très majoritaire
mais on voit quand même que certaines
voies politiques sont plutôt favorables
à aux Palestiniens sans être favorable
au hamass bien sûr il faut tout de suite
différencier en revanche des voix se
font de plus en plus entendre pour un
cesser le feu donc c'est voilà on arrête
les hostilités sur la ligne en bleu là
que l'on voit et on essaie de discuter
les uns les uns avec les autres c'est
une option qui est rejetée avec par le
gouvernement israélien tant qu'il n'y a
pas de libération d'otage et qui dit
mais en fait un cess le feu ne donnerait
ne donnerait seulement que du temps au
combattant du Hamas pour se renforcer et
pour venir nous attaquer derrière donc
je pense que nous allons entendre dans
les prochains jours de plus en plus de
voix s'élever pour un cesser le feu ou
une trêve humanitaire voilà en se disant
il faut aller soigner les blessés
soigner les
gens mais mais qu'un cesser le feu sera
compliqué à obtenir de la part des
autorités israéliennes qui veulent à la
fois fois venger leur morts et se
débarrasser enfin une bonne fois pour
toute du Hamas qui est une organisation
terroriste qui a fait plus de 1400 morts
il faut imaginer que si on rapporte ça à
la population française c'est comme si
le Hamas avait tué 9000 personnes en
France donc c'est vraiment colossal pour
eux c'est un choc national et je crois
que et no nos envoyés spéciaux
l'écrivent très bien je crois que en
Occident et en Europe particulièrement
on a un peu oublié ça mais que pour eux
c'est un traumatisme collectif tel qu'il
y a une incompréhension de la part d'un
certain nombre d'une grande la
population israélienne de ce de C de ces
appels au cesser le feu I qui juge
improductif selon vous parlez du bilan
du 7 octobre il y a aussi le bilan à
Gaza qui est annoncé par le par le par
le Hamas et qui fait état de de plus de
10000 morts ça presque presque 11000 oui
presque 11000 maintenant est-ce que
c'est est-ce que ces chiffres il faut
les prendre avec les pincettes bien sûr
il faut les prendre avec les pincettes
déjà pour une raison très simple c'est
qu'on il
est même impossible en réalité de le
vérifier de manière indépendante
et c'est aussi une guerre de l'image et
de l'information le le Hamas est un
mouvement terroriste et veut jouer sur
le le le le le sentiment David contre
Goliath en réalité et de montrer que ils
se font vraiment massacrés par une armée
israélienne surpuissante qui tue qui des
enfants qui attaqueent des hôpitaux et
cetera c'est aussi un message politique
à destination à la fois des opinions
arabe mais aussi des opinions mondiales
pour grossir de plus en plus ce chiffre
ce ce ces nombres même maintenant pardon
pour voilà pour avoir un rapport
défavorable en pour les Palestiniens et
essayer d'accroître leur soutien à
travers le monde en revanche ce qui est
tout à fait certain c'est que de telles
opérations sont meurtrières des deux
côtés que le fait qu'il demeureent des
civils dans la ville de Gaza et dans le
nord de la bande d'Israël dans la bande
de Gaza où l'armée israélienne
intervient est extrêmement compliqué
déjà pour des termes tactique évident
mais aussi parce que ça va occasionner
des morts même si l'armée israélienne et
on le sait depuis plusieurs années est
est assez doué pour frapper avec
précision des bâtiments si jamais il y a
énormément de personnes naturellement ça
fera des des des pertes civiles donc
pour éviter cela il faut absolument que
tous les civils qui se qui se trouvent
dans le nord de la bande de Gaza évacue
vers le sud et c'est là où ils seront le
plus en sécurité ce qui n'empêche pas il
faut il faut être honnête des des des
bombardements ponctuels de l'armée
israélienne sur cette bande Sud
h effectivement euh c'est c'est bien le
préciser aussi proton dans les
commentaires qui nous dit avez-vous des
informations sur d'éventuels pour parler
avec l'Autorité palestinienne de la part
des canaux diplomatiques États-Unis
européens ou autres pour pour envisager
une alternative au Hamas donc on va
parler des des des scénarios d'après
alors on n'y est pas encore forcément
mais la question se pose quelle suite à
tout ça alors pour l'autorité
palestinene on sait que le le premier à
s'y être rendu à ramala donc le siège de
l'autorité palestinienne et avoir
rencontré Marmoud Abbas qui est le
dirigeant de l'autorité palestinens
c'était Emmanuel Macron ça n'a pas
abouti sur voilà un projet politique en
tout cas que nous connaissons à date
Anthony blinken le secrétaire d'État
américain s'y'est également rendu ces
dernières heures pour discuter pour
penser à
l'après le le Premier ministre israélien
Benjamin netanahou a déclaré hier dans
une interview à la télévision américaine
que l'armée israélienne assurerait la
sécurité dans la bande de Gaza alors ça
a été très flou ça ça ça sa formule
exacte c'est assurer la sécurité dans la
bande de Gaza on ne sait pas ce que ça
veut dire est-ce que c'est une
occupation militaire est-ce que c'est
une intervention de l'ONU on ne sait pas
exactement ce que ce qu'entendait ce que
sous-entendait en tout cas Benjamin
netaniaou ce qui est certain c'est que
pour Israël il est inconcevable qu'il y
ait à nouveau le Hamas et elle fera tout
pour avoir soit une Autorité
palestinienne avec laquelle elle puisse
échanger mais qui soit moins militarisée
que le Hamas et un retour de l'autorité
palestinenne je rappelle que l'autorité
le fatatin le parti de Mar mouabas qui
est la tête de l'Autorité palestinienne
dirigeait la bande de Gaza jusqu'en 2007
en 2006 il y a eu des élections le Hamas
les a gagné et a pris le pouvoir par la
force en 2007 en en chassant le fata
depuis il y a eu plusieurs tentatives
voilà de réconciliation entre les deux
parti qui n'ont à date en tout cas pas
encore abouti pour les scénarios de
l'après il y a donc plusieurs scénarios
effectivement une occupation militaire
israélienne complète et on c'est
concevable l'armée israélienne l'a
rejeté et les États-Unis d'Amérique on
dit que c'était une très mauvaise idée
pour Israël on peut imaginer également
qu'il pourrait y avoir une force
interposition de l'ONU on pourrait
également imaginer qu'il y ait une force
de pays arabes qui puisse s'interposer
pour y assurer la sécurité c'est une
proposition qui avait été rejeté en tout
cas pour le moment par un certain nombre
de pays arabes enfin on peut aussi
imaginer que des des colons viennent se
réinstaller dans les colonies qui
avaient été évacué en 2005 et dans ces
cas-là que ce soit un scénario un peu
comme en SI Jordanie c'està-dire avec
des zones qui soient sous l'autorité
militaire israélienne et des zones qui
soient sous l'autorité d'une nouvelle
Autorité palestinienne à Gaza à date on
ne sait pas ce qui va se passer tous les
scénarios sont
envisageables mais il va bien bien
falloir y penser assez rapidement
puisque l'armée israélienne avance et
avance vite et le jour où elle arrivera
à neutraliser le Hamas il faudra enfin
avoir une solution durable pour la bande
de Gaza qui ne soit pas un foyer
terroriste aux portes de l'État d'Israël
oui forcément il va falloir se se poser
cette cette question j'ai une autre
question aussi d'un d'un d'un internaute
mackavel mais alors c'est une question
économique qui nous demande quel serait
l'impact économique je vais pas vous la
poser à mais forcément puisque je c'est
pas forcément votre domaine je le sais
je vais je vais je vais renvoyer par
contre nos internautes aux articles qu'a
fait le Figaro sur le sujet la guerre
Isra baisse risque d'avoir de graves
conséquences économiques alerte le chef
de la Banque mondiale je vous renvoie
maavel effectivement à tous nos articles
sur le sujet peut-être juste un mot euh
l'armée israélienne a mobilisé 350000
soldats donc c'est des jeunes hommes qui
dans le civil faisaient tourner
l'économie et un certain nombre de
dirigeants israéliens se sont inquiétés
d'un tel nombre parce qu'ils disent que
cela pourrait faire chuter naturellement
l'économie qui appelle peut-être à
réduire le dispositif pour pouvoir faire
repartir l'économie pour le moment c'est
pas une option qui a été retenue oui
parce qu'on imagine bien qu'un pays
aussi peu peupl entre guillemets à qui
on retire 350000 forces viv forcément ça
c'est des impacts très important ça euh
voilà ça ça a des ça a des conséquences
euh j'avais aussi une question sur un
missile yeménit qui a ce qui intéresse a
no internautes un missile yéménite qui a
été intercepté par Israël au-delà de
l'atmosphère terrestre est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en parler exactement alors
c'est un missile qui a été tiré depuis
le yéen le la provenance est
probablement le groupe des outils qui
est un groupe qui est en rébellion
contre ce gouvernement au Yémen alors le
yéen c'est compliqué est qu'il y a
plusieurs groupes voilà qui s'affrontent
pour le pouvoir mais les outils c'est un
groupe qui est sout tenu par l'Iran donc
c'est un allié de l'Iran comme le
hzbolah au Liban au Liban sud au nord
donc d'Israël et qui a tiré un missile
qui était intercepté vers Israël ça
n'est pas la première fois un missile
avait déjà de missilees et un drone
pardon avait déjà été intercepté par la
marine américaine il y a une dizaine
petite dizaine de jours maintenant et
les outils dans une déclaration filmée
avaient déclaré la guerre à l'État
d'Israël et on soutient bien sûr à la
cause du du Hamas dans dans l'enclave de
Gaza euh c'est aussi l'une des craintes
des États-Unis et de beaucoup
d'observateurs géostratégiques est-ce
que ce conflit va va s'étendre on sait
que l'Iran fait la guerre par par
procuration pardon pas par proxy pour
utiliser le terme français qu'elle
utilise voilà des milice dans plusieurs
pays on sait qu'elle l'a fait en Irak en
Syrie on sait qu'avec le hzbollah elle
le fait au Liban au Yémen bien sûr avec
les outil et et la question que tout le
monde se pose c'est va-t-elle demander à
toutes ces à toutes ces milices qui lui
sont redevables d'engager une guerre
plus importante ou en tout cas d'engager
plus de troupes contre Israël et auquel
cas il pourrait y avoir une déflagration
régionale et encore une fois c'est le
scénario le plus redouté non seulement
par Israël mais aussi par les Américains
et les Européens oui effectivement on
imagine une comment dire une une
escalade finalement dans dans la région
ce que tout le monde tous les acteurs ne
veulent pas forcément effectivement
merci beaucoup en tout cas ami d'AV a
nous merci à vous les internautes du
Figaro d'avoir été nombreux à nous
suivre je remercie également le service
infographie vous pouvez retrouver toutes
leurs cartes sur le site du Figaro vous
pouvezou es les inform en direct sur
site peut-être juste un mot pour saluer
quand même le travail exceptionnel de
nos correspondants à Jérusalem et de nos
envoyés spéciaux pour qui voilà c'est
c'est leur métier mais c'est aussi
quelque chose de de très remarquable ce
qu'ils font depuis bientôt un mois et je
tiens vraiment à les saluer ici très
bien merci beaucoup merci effectivement
à eux pour le travail de très grande
qualité qu'ils fournissent leurs papiers
son retrouver bien sûr sur le site du
Figaro et dans votre journal dans votre
journal du Figaro tous les jours
forcément merci et moi je vous dis à
bientôt pour nouveau live sur Figaro
live EEE